we're on problem number four and they
give us a theorem it says a triangle has
at most one obtuse angle fair enough
eduardo is proving the theorem above by
contradiction
he began by assuming so the way you
prove by a contradiction you're like
okay well what if this weren't true
let me prove that that can't happen well
let's see what he did anyway he began by
assuming that in triangle abc
angle a and b are both obtuse
which theorem will eduardo use to reach
a contradiction
okay
so he's he's saying let me draw this
what eduardo is trying to do
the way i'm drawing it it's actually
very hard so this is actually not drawn
at all to scale so he's saying that
angle a and angle b are both ob2 so this
means that this angle is greater than 90
that let's say that's angle a
and this is angle b and it's also
greater than 9. that's what obtuse means
right which theorem will aldrado reach
to reach a contradiction
well you know before even reading the
choices think about it what do we know
about triangles that all of the angles
add up to 180 degrees right so if this
is angle a this is angle b and let's say
let's call this angle c
right
we know
a
plus b
plus c
have to be equal to 180 degrees
right or another way to view it is
c
well let me think of it this way c is
equal to 180
minus a
minus b
or another way you could think of it i'm
just writing it a bunch of different
ways c is equal to 180 minus a plus b
right now let me ask you a question if
we assume from the get go as eduardo did
if we assume that both a and b are
greater than 90 degrees what's a plus b
going to be at least greater than if
this is greater than 90 and that's
greater than 90 then a plus b is going
to be greater than 90 plus 90. so this
has to be greater than 180.
so if this is greater than 180 and we're
subtracting it from 180 so this
essentially says if angle a
is
greater than 90
and
angle b is greater than 90 then what we
can deduce is from this statement right
here from this equation right here
if this and this is greater than 90 then
this whole term is greater than 180 so
then the deduction would be that c has
to be less than zero and we can't have
negative angles
so right there
right there that is the contradiction
now let's see which which and then you
would say okay then therefore you cannot
have two angles that are more than 90
degrees or two angles that are obtuse
and that would be your proof by
contradiction but let's see what what
eduardo let's see if two angle let's see
if we what we did can be phrased in one
of these choices if two angles of a
triangle are equal the sides opposite
the angles are equal no if two
supplementaries are uh angle if two
supplementary angles are equal
the angle each measure 90. well that
yeah that when we didn't use that
the largest angle of triangle is
opposite the longest side note the sum
of the measures of the angles of a
triangle 180 yep that's the first thing
we wrote down right there
so it's choice d
that's the theorem eduardo used to reach
the contradiction
next question
problem five
problem five okay this one
use the
okay so this is let me it's a big
question
let me see if i can copy and paste the
whole thing
i've copied it
all right
i think it all fits in the window let's
see it says use
the proof to answer the question below
so given that side a b
side a b is congruent to side b c so we
could say you know that side is equal to
that side that's given
d is the midpoint of ac so that means d
is equal distance between ac so that
means that a d and a c are equal length
let me write that so a d
and a c are of equal length or a d and d
c
prove that triangle
abd
abd is congruent to triangle c c
b
d
all right and just so you know congruent
triangles are triangles that are the
same in every way except they might have
been rotated and skewed and well not
skewed they could have been rotated in
some way if you had similar triangles
then you could also have different side
measures they're just kind of the same
shape but they could be expanded and
they could be expanded or contracted in
some way if you're congruent you have
similar try you have a similar triangles
but they also have the same side lengths
but even though they have the same side
lengths they could be flipped over like
you can just look at this one abd looks
like it's a mirror image of dba or dbc
right so just eyeballing it already
feels like they're congruent to
triangles let's see how they go about
proving it
so statement one
a b
is congruent to bc they give us that
d is the midpoint of ac right that was
given fair enough
a d is congruent to c d
a d is congruent to c d right that's
because d is the midpoint of ac we did
that part right there definition of
midpoint fair enough
b d is congruent to b d of course
right
anything is congruent to itself
so we could just put three that just
says you know the bd for that triangle
is the same length as a bd for this
triangle or enough reflexive property
fancy word for a very sim simple idea
and then finally they say
triangle abd is congruent to cbd
okay well i mean from the get go we've
already using these statements we've
already shown that they have the same
exact three side measures right both
triangles have a side of length bd both
triangles have a side of length ad or dc
and both triangles have a side of length
ba so all of their sides are the same
length
and that's that's what we know after the
first three steps
so what reason can we be what reason can
be used to prove that the triangles are
congruent we just said these three steps
we show that all the sides are the same
so this ss that you see
what reason that means side side side
side side side
and that's just
the argument that you use in in your
geometry class to say that
all three sides of both triangles are
congruent
this means that you have an angle an
angle and a side this means that you
have an angle and then the side between
the two angles and then the next angle
that all of those are congruent and this
says it one of the side and then the
angle and then the other side that those
are congruent we'll probably run into
those in the next couple of questions
but anyway this showed that all three
sides of those both triangles are equal
and then so
we could say by the side side side
i guess we could say by the side side
side reasoning
i'm not that good with with terminology
by the side side side reasoning these
are both congruent triangles and i said
that's you know that's kind of one of
the ways of thinking about a congruent
triangle is that all the sides are going
to be the same length
next question
next question
all right
all right
in the figure below a b
is greater than b c
okay so this side is greater than that
side although the way they drew it they
all look the same
so let's see what we can do
if we assume that
that measure of angle a is equal to
measure of angle c
measure of angle a
did they say measure of angle
a is equal to measure of angle c
okay
okay
it follows that a b is equal to bc right
a b is equal to bc
and i don't know if you've run into this
already but you learned that if you have
two angles that are congruent
or if the measures are the same this is
essentially saying that angle a is
congruent to angle c they instead just
wrote it as the measures of the angles
are equal and that's what the definition
of congruence is is that the measures of
the angle are equal
you could have written angle a
is congruent to angle c
but anyway if you have two angles that
are equal
then the angles that are then the sides
that are opposite those angles are also
going to be equal so this side right
here is going to be equal to that side
and that's what they wrote here it
follows that a b
is equal to bc
fair enough
then they say this contradicts the state
the given statement that a b is greater
than bc
right
right i mean you know it says it follows
that a b is equal to bc and it
contradicts this statement okay where
are they going with this
what conclusion can be drawn from this
con from this contradiction
from this contradiction okay
let's see measure of angle a is equal to
measure of angle b
no i can't measure of angle a is equal
to measure of angle b no that's not the
case i mean you know i could think of an
example these could both be 30 degree
angles
if these are both 30 degree angles add
up to 60 then we'd have to get this
would have to be 120 for them to all out
to 180 and it would completely gel with
everything else we've learned so a is
definitely not right that a does not
have to be equal to b
measure of a does not equal the measure
of angle b
measure of angle a does not equal the
measure of angle b
well they could right i mean all of
these angles could be 60 degrees you
know we haven't said that b definitely
does not equal a this could be 60 that
could be 60 and so could this be 60 and
then we'd be dealing with an equilateral
triangle
so i don't think that's right either
measure of angle a is equal to measure
of angle c
measure of angle a
is oh i see what they're saying here so
they're saying
sorry and this is my bad they're saying
a b is definitely greater than bc
right a b is definitely greater than bc
now
they said if if we assume that measure
of angle a is equal to measure of angle
c it follows that a b is equal to bc
they didn't say that this is definitely
true they just said that if we assumed
that this is true right but they didn't
say that you know this is you know a
definite case and that's where the
contradiction came because if we assumed
it then a b could not be greater than bc
right because then a b would equal bc
so now i see what they're asking
so this is this is an assumption this
isn't actually proven to be true so this
contradicts the given statement that a b
is greater than bc right that's true
what conclusion can be drawn from this
contradiction
so we made the assumption that the
measure of angle a is equal to the
measure of angle c that followed that
these two sides are equal which
contradicted the given statement
therefore we know that the measures of
these two angles cannot be equal to each
other right because if they
if they were then we would contradict
the given assumption
so
we know from the contradiction that the
measure of angle a
cannot equal the measure of angle c
and we can't make that assumption
because it leads to a contradiction
so the correct answer is d
all right
i'll see you in the next video